oh my wife don't say that
[Music]
[Music]
hi
no no don't you didn't scare me at all i
knew you were there you're probably
wondering why is he so calm right now
that's because on this week's episode
we're meeting up with two of comedies
yogis senseis shamans if you will that's
technotaro and ian edwards we're gonna
find out what the buzz is all about here
at beet takaria and we're about to do a
sting operation into flavor
that's right honey we're bringing
vegan tacos to tacos contolo this season
and this might be the last episode i
ever do because these puns are bad
i'm really excited because the chef at
bita karia put a very special thoughtful
menu together omakase style
let's go
oh yeah i need to eat a vegetable
oh boy
ian pig yay
two of my favorite comics with three
letters in their first name what's up
what's up man what's up y'all how are
you oh man you saw it here first
exclusive what y'all came in holding
hands yeah boom
this is great to just do your show with
my boo no i'm i'm flattered thank you
guys for being here i have a hell of a
date night set up for y'all because i
heard that you guys were vegan yes yeah
yeah
yeah
and then and in love the fact that you
have to say boo makes me think that is
not really a boo thing are you doubting
that he's attracted no no no no not at
all are you offending me
my book
well hey thank you guys so much for
coming out do you usually go out this
far for food i don't leave my house
typically really yeah our house
here okay
i'm glad you can't
because i was feeling a little early we
got a hell of a spread you guys hungry
yeah let's do it all right come on in
that's why we're here so let's
come here just to talk to you at the
gate of the
[Music]
place so my name is alex and we are at
vita creek finally after working in
so many kitchens i decided to do my own
solo restaurant and we end up with this
as a skateboarder my dream was to be a
professional but then one day you know
i couldn't skate anymore
a really bad injury the culinary school
was really expensive so i decided to
move to la so then i had a chance to
work with really really good chefs fine
dining
experience
helped me a lot to make tacos because
presentation is always important you eat
with your
smell and with your eyes i decided to
start challenging myself offering people
to sit down and do a course meal we're
doing the vegan just completely
beginning tacos and then it was a
challenge for me to like actually adapt
all those needs to make it taste good
you know so today we're making uh the
aguachilia with bamboo and the mushrooms
with a little guacamole planting chips
then we had the uh
mole i was tired of cleaning the flowers
in the floor i founded a somoli with the
bougainvillea in some part of mexico and
then i decided to make my own so the
tortilla on the taco is pink because i
blanch the burgundy leaves and the puree
so the next one is going to be the
empanada with la coche a lot of people
call it the mexican truffle it's a
fungus it grows in the corn so i decided
to to mix it with the truffles and then
so we have the tortilla we put a little
bit of the charcoal and we stuff it with
almond cheese did with lacocia which
grass polanas we fry it and then we
serve it with a coconut cream salsa
verde with pipicha and then a pasote as
well
so pastor is we marinate the mushrooms
on it and we grill them
and then once we serve it we serve it
with a little bit of chile arbol salsa
pineapple the reason why i decided to do
tacos is because i was losing myself i
was in my
my culture i was in my identity if i
have all this background of like making
original mexican food why try to do
something else when you can actually do
your own i don't call it my job this is
my life this is what i do you know
[Music]
thank you so much thank you let's spread
dance
tacos for each of you guys wow so first
of all welcome my name is alex hi what's
up
thank you alex so it cost me takeriya
because when we uh started creating the
uh the the soul of bitter korea the
identity of the korea uh i i brought a
shaman to clean the energy of the place
because it was it used to be another
place before what was it before it was a
barbecue joint oh okay very famous but
i've got over here so many years out of
here so many years but the guy passed
away
i lived my life with energies that's how
i got my life yeah so i brought a shaman
shaman clean the whole energy and he can
recommend us to add flags in the roof
when we're gonna do that we find be
hyped on there oh
and then i said you know what leave it
alone we're not gonna get stuck that's
the ship right of course not we have a
deal between between them this is my
hood up there is their hood so they
don't cross they don't tell each
so they're reasonable bees
they're reasonable would you say that
they behave yeah all right come on let's
uh tell us about this show here starting
from the bottom i said that joke sorry
you guys today you guys gonna have a
vegan feast uh beginner chile i want you
so we have poached bamboos yeah jelly
mushrooms a little bit of my shimmery
mushrooms as well and then the sauce is
made with a kombu and then a seaweed a
little garlic soranos and then we finish
it with a guacamelee on top and cilantro
so uh we have a bugambilia mole
uh we had a bougainvillea tortilla on
the bottom beets to substitute the
chicken with the molly it has bugambilia
we finish it with a little bit
almond cheese
we're not gonna get stuffed why wouldn't
it right
would you say that they be hey
so i decided to combine both of this um
oh that was only two of them you
described yeah
a little bit of pineapple jelly dried
pineapple on top with the herbal salsa
on top i gotta be honest all i heard was
bugamilia and mushrooms
this is amazing man thank you so much
before it gets cold all right and then
enjoy thank you guys again thank you
thank
you that's good
really good you can really
taste like the citrus
oven just coming together they got a
little bamboo in there what is it like
to be a touring comedian and be vegan
that's gotta be hard i remember a long
time ago i was in switzerland
in lugano which is like the italian
side of switzerland i went to an italian
restaurant
i was explaining to the waiter
and i'm vegan and then i wanted some
adjustments made mm-hmm and he looked at
me
i was like no
i said no he wouldn't change it for you
she hurt you out
he hurts me out
the chef is not gonna
all right just bring whatever you got
[Laughter]
all right what do you guys think of this
bugambilia one
it's pretty good it's sweet
i have not uh had um
tacos like this all right what about you
yeah not like this like the presentation
the way he came out and explained
everything
like it was written
in a novel mm-hmm you know it's so good
you like this one
yeah man to me this is the first i've
never had a uh taco with this kind of
like leaf the bugambilia as we're
speaking about the aesthetics of the
food and the aesthetics of a stand-up
comic let's talk about that for a little
bit like i used to have a comb over i'm
completely bald now
and i used to look a lot darker uh you
used to i mean i i like to think so ian
yeah you still think i'm dorky you
shouldn't think so oh okay well
this is a comb over that i had now you
couldn't really tell that this was a
come-over yeah we came okay well it's
clear i mean that's what people do to
that's a comedian come over here so i
used to spray it in lock it in and then
sometime a gust of wind would come and
it would have blew up now this was very
over a blow over yeah i will say that
comedy let me be comfortable with this
because i talked about it it's like i
started talking like this was the first
joke that killed for me and i talked
about my comb over and and that
experience you look like a mexican jerry
lewis
[Laughter]
what would you tell your younger self
here
you're not in as shape as you thought
you were just taking that
because you don't have a cameraman tell
you to try all these different poses
so you just do it and then later on like
why did i listen to
the pictures come out and you're like
that looks so tight just some guy
douchey and stupid some guy trying to
build this performance we're gonna come
up with some poses so we can end this
photo session and then that's what we
get i've just recently learned to smile
during photos let me see your smile
wow
still some work to do
this is so good this is great this is a
empanada
but this doesn't look like an empanada
this doesn't look like
all right this is dark yeah because of
the
the breading that goes charcoal my skin
is gonna look great all right let's go
into this next taco here this is their
alpasor version of it
pineapple
cilantro you guys both as comics is like
i really respect and admire are you the
comic today that you wanted to be when
you started comedy i thought when i
started that that was who i was as a
comedian
and i didn't really understand that i
would evolve or grow i think i like
my style
i know there are people that don't like
my stuff right i like myself
what have they told you in arizona
before the pandemic
i was on stage and this woman was
sitting in like this
front row
it was so distracting yeah i said
you don't you don't like this huh and
she was like
no
i said my name is on the marquee
and you're sitting front row center
what i'm what happened here
and she said she brought me she pointed
to her friend and i was like oh okay
well i just found it amusing
it is pretty fun it's funny you know
when somebody doesn't like you
and the rest of the room seems to it's
you know it's it's hard to be like upset
about that yeah i'm going to use that
periodically throughout the set yeah
because now the audience knows all this
information yeah
and everybody's laughing you cut back to
the person that's not yeah it's an
inside joke being built in that moment
still no movement you just go back
come back
sometimes i get mad right i'm not trying
to create conflict but yeah this person
can tighten you up yeah throughout your
set so if you don't do something to like
keep yourself like loose then they win
yeah they win
heckled in silence yeah you know what i
mean are you guys ready for dessert oh
yes oh yes can you tell us a little
about what we have here
it's a chocolate
uh gnocchis a little bit of banana sauce
on the bottom
of uh chocolate ice cream okay and then
dehydrated bananas with pecans
your presentation is killer yeah thank
you very much very beautiful so
so ted you got a podcast called don't
ask tig
yes it's an advice podcast where i have
a different uh
where i have a different um
guest on to um
help the listeners with whatever
problem they have big or small i try my
best
and then if i can't come up with
anything then it goes off the rails you
know you got any questions for tig as
far as uh trying to get some advice
well he's known me too long and i'm not
who he would go to for
a good thing i'm stupid enough to ask
take a real question
to help my life
what's wrong with you
uh how long does somebody wait
to like fart
in front of somebody that you're dating
how long did we wait
ah what i think during our first kiss
yeah we both we both released yeah yeah
um
simultaneously yeah yeah
releases that one
and then we actually blamed it on each
other that's great and we get gold
and we release some more love our first
shark right there and then you know
there it is with you guys thank you so
much i hope you guys enjoyed the dessert
you guys like the dessert so good oh
can i still finish this even though when
they cut the camera sure yeah yeah
this is tacos contour season three
we'll see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is jesus draco i'm the
host of tacos contolo and don't forget
to like and subscribe you can watch more
right here hurry watch another episode
before your boss comes in and you get
fired for real this time